people in germany are facing tighter
restrictions as the country grapples
with a high number of coronavirus
infections
leaders of the federal and regional
governments are meeting in a few hours
time to consider a range of measures
many of which are expected to target
unvaccinated people the aim is to bring
down infection rates and to relieve the
pressure on hospitals leaders are also
expected to discuss mandatory
vaccinations
the chancellor's office is waiting for
its next occupant but already the
incoming chancellor has made his first
u-turn
olaf schultz is getting behind mandatory
vaccinations
members of parliament will be able to
vote as they wish on compulsory
vaccinations which could come into force
at the beginning of next year in
february or early march
people can get ready
parliament is expected to decide
promptly on mandatory vaccinations
but forcing millions of people to get
jabbed would be a big problem for
schultz's future coalition partners the
free democrats
this would be a serious bodily
infringement hopefully we will agree
that you can't force people to be
vaccinated
the outgoing government wants to see
more vaccinations which could also be
done at dentists and chemists and
germany's health minister says vaccines
for children
could be ready earlier than expected
from the middle of december we'll have a
vaccine for 5 to 11 year olds that is
good news for parents and children many
of them can't wait to get the vaccine to
protect themselves
the vaccine commission's recommendations
are still pending
the federal and regional authorities
could also tighten regulations for
example bringing in the so-called 2g
rule in shops
it is important that we get this rule
throughout germany in effect we will
have a lockdown for unvaccinated people
they won't be able to go shopping so
easily
unvaccinated people could still buy food
and medicines but would face
wide-ranging social restrictions
the debate on compulsory vaccination is
likely to be heated
we can speak now to our political
correspondent benjamin alvarez gruber
good morning to you benjamin the
outgoing health minister yen span always
said that covet 19 vaccinations would
not be mandatory so why are germany's
lawmakers considering this move
good morning sumi the outgoing health
minister is not the only high-ranking
politician member of the government
who's changed his position when it comes
to mandatory vaccination also the
incoming chancellor olaf schultz back in
september said that it's not the time to
talk about a maxi about a vaccine
mandate and some state leaders who were
even against the vaccine mandate for
people working in certain professions
like for example hospitals and nursing
homes are now calling for this general
vaccine mandate
what many politicians were hoping for is
to have a higher vaccination rate that
has not reached 70 percent of fully
vaccinated people here in germany and
that's what they're considering to see
if something like that would work as
many people who have still chosen to
stay and vaccinated would hope to
try to get the job once they had the
possibility and now in germany well
there are the possibilities now for
several weeks and months to get the job
they're thinking about another way of
trying to
improve this number of vaccinations so
that's what they're now thinking about
this new vaccination mandate that could
come into force next year
beyond a mandate what other measures are
being considered
what they're trying to do and what they
will discuss today is to try to limit
indoor activities to close bars to close
clubs as well to ask for this health
pass showing that someone is either
fully vaccinated or recovered from the
virus and also to limit and sometimes
also to prohibit these indoor activities
that are still taking place that's
everything is being done and they're
thinking about the hospitals that are
trying to not get to the situation where
they cannot accept any new patient it is
believed that more than 75 percent
so three out of four non-critical
surgeries now need to be postponed in
germany and that's of course something
that they want to avoid and try to lower
that number as well
over the weekend we saw a prominent
group of scientists here calling for an
immediate nationwide lockdown to relieve
pressure on hospitals how likely is that
to happen
earlier this week the country's
constitutional um
organization said that the lockdown that
was in place last year was abiding to
the constitution this partial lockdown
it's important to see what type of
lockdown we are talking about if it's a
full lockdown if it's a partial lockdown
or if it's locked down in some states
like a patchwork of agreements but what
the president of the association of
intensive care units said that
independently of what measures will be
decided there will be around 6 000
patients in this intensive care unit and
by christmas so of course that's also a
measure and that's why health officials
and people working in hospitals are
calling for strict measures as soon as
possible
our political correspondent benjamin
alvarez gruber good to talk to you
now to some other developments in the
pandemic new data from south africa
suggests that the omicron variant could
evade some immunity provided by vaccines
but the shots are still likely to
prevent severe disease
the u.s has identified a case of omicron
for the first time
and south korea has halted quarantine
exemptions for fully vaccinated
travelers as it deals with record case
numbers
you